getting a sneaky look at scenes that got
cut from the harry potter movies gives
us a whole new perspective
on our favorite characters and their
relationships these deleted moments
would have made such a difference if
they'd made the final cut
romantic highlights character
revelations amazing music
they're all here even a whole character
that got cut
go behind the scenes to see what else
happened to harry
ron hermione ginny and the squad
a lot of the lighter moments came the
first movie as we all got engrossed in
what being a hogwarts student was really
like
so a longer scene of back and forth
banter would have been a-okay with us
like hermione scolding ron for playing
with his chocolate frog cards instead of
studying for their final exams
ask me any question all right what are
the three most crucial ingredients in a
forgetfulness potion
i forgot in the beginning harry's wonder
at the difference between the muggle
world and the magical world made it all
the more exciting to enter that
enchanting place
for viewers too and what showed the
difference particularly well
are all the scenes where harry and
hagrid are in the muggle world so we
would have loved to watch the boy who
lived and the giant taking a ride on the
tube
train on the london underground
especially when hagrid says he'd love to
have a dragon
and gets a funny look from a commuter i
love a track
you'd like a dragon flashlight is
understood
it's always good when harry can play a
part in solving a mystery
rather than hermione all the time and
this happens in a deleted scene where he
discovers a major clue about the
philosopher's stone
he's reading dumbledore's chocolate frog
card when he finds a mention of
partner nicholas flamel harry knew the
name sounded familiar as he remembered
reading it on the train that first day
the idea of a squib someone who was born
into a wizarding family but hasn't got
any magic powers
isn't introduced in the movies until the
fifth installment but it would have
cropped up in the second film had they
not cut the scene where harry and ron
discover filter's secret and the fact
that the caretaker was desperate to
improve his magical ability
with a correspondence course in
beginners magic from quick spell
mr filch you dropped this it goes some
way to explaining why filch is quite so
meme spirited he's concerned that he
doesn't truly fit in
or measure up at hogwarts in a deleted
scene from the prisoner of azkaban
we get to see professor mcgonagall in
her pajamas in the gryffindor common
room
and we get to see the rest of gryffindor
house in their pjs too
talking about how sirius black had
managed to break in
the professor asked sir cadogan who'd
been acting as the gryffindor's portrait
how it all went down certainly good lady
you had the password
this would have further built up the
tension about sirius while giving us
a fun insight into everyone's nightwear
choices
we would have loved to see more of the
weird sister's performance at the yule
ball in the goblet of fire
it's not only fun to see the brit pop
legend jarvis crocker
rock out to wizard pop but also to see
the hogwarts students
acting like regular students dancing and
being carefree
sure we get a brief glimpse of this in
the final cut but this deleted scene
runs the whole length of the song and by
connecting with the students as being
just like
us we can empathize more with them when
it comes to the battle of hogwarts at
the end of the franchise
a lot of the quieter moments in the
movies got cut and that's understandable
they don't necessarily move the plot
along or have a script
but these scenes make us feel so much
more for the characters
like when harry takes a somber moment to
reflect on sirius's passing
the deleted scene from the order of the
phoenix shows us not only how harry is
feeling but also how ron is always there
for him
trying to help thanks ron i'm not really
in the mood
but as happens so often with harry he
chooses to face this moment on his own
rather than let ron stay with him
before dumbledore's end in the
half-blood prince there's a moving scene
where we're shown each of the characters
reflecting on the events about to come
the montage is set to a beautiful piece
of music sung by the hogwarts choir
it's so atmospheric and gives us viewers
a moment to reflect and let it all sink
in too
snape's face is of particular
significance given his part in what's to
come
it would have been quite the spoiler for
the final two movies had it not been cut
harry and jenny's relationship has
caused a lot of debate amongst fans with
many people not shipping this eventual
couple
at all but if more scenes of the pair of
them being each other's rock had been
shown
perhaps they would have got more support
from the fandom like this moment
when they're marching down the stairs in
the deathly hallows that subtle
holding of hands being there for one
another while being silent
speaks volumes of their support for each
other
given the number of times hermione
outsmarted ron we'd love to have seen
more scenes where he got to be the one
with the knowledge and skills for a
change and she was impressed by him
and we got that in this deleted scene
from the deathly hallows part 1
where ron shows hermione how to skim
stones it would have added more depth to
the growing relationship between them
and hey it would have also taught us all
how to become master stone skimmers
just follow ron's advice first select a
flat stone
the flatter the better get quite low
lean back a bit
and flick the wrist so i'm back
it's too much it's good there are
certain characters that we would have
loved to see more of on screen
and victor crum is certainly high up on
that list he did
actually appear in a deleted scene at
bill and fleur's wedding in the deathly
hallows part 1.
it's pretty difficult to find the actual
scene just stills
but we've dug up some footage of the
pair actually dancing together
it's important for hermione's character
development because as emma watson says
she's coming into a new role and she's a
young woman now
the look on ron's face
aunt petunia was never a likable
character but jk rowling typically gives
each one of her creations more depth
than being all good or all bad
and had this scene from the deathly
hallows part 1 made the final cut we
would have gotten
insight into the more human loving side
of lily's jealous unpleasant sister
it's fitting that harry finally gets to
see this side of his mom's sister as
they're finally parting ways for good
you didn't just lose a mother that night
in godric's horror you know
i lost her sister remus lupin and nym
fedora tonks were such an
awesome couple whose lives got cut short
tragically early
and what makes their eventual fate all
the more heartbreaking is being reminded
of their young son
teddy which is exactly what this deleted
scene in the deathly hallows part 2
shows us when tonks runs to lupin and
tells him why she's left their little
one at home
he'll sleep till dawn and snore like his
father
it's you that needs me tonight
ron and hermione's relationship is one
of the highlights of the franchise so
why would they choose to cut any moment
that adds depth to their romance
especially the moment where ron's about
to tell hermione that he loves her in
the deathly hallows part 2.
given that they're being chased by a
snake that doesn't have the most amazing
cgi
perhaps it was to do with the special
effects but the emotion in the scene and
hermione's brilliant response
should have earned a spot in the final
cut i don't want you to say anything
that you wouldn't say if you want but be
killed by giant snakes
anyone who loves nearly headless nick
will be up in arms about this bit of
behind the scenes information
they actually filmed scenes with peeves
too but those moments never made it into
the final cut of the first movie
british comedian rick male is known for
his anarchic humor
so he was absolutely perfect as the
mischievous poltergeist
i was peeves in harry potter he
explained that he kept making the other
actors
laugh when he was playing the part so it
took quite a while to film
but a month later the decision was made
to cut his scenes
he would have definitely added some
great light relief you're not in the
film
what so we've cut you out the film which
of these deleted moments do you think
should have made the final cut
how have they changed your view on the
movies be sure to let us know in the
comments and hit that like
button to show your love for the harry
potter franchise thanks for watching